monsieur le premier ministre
l'observatoire de la délinquance et des
réponses pénales il vient de publier sa
dernière enquête de victimisation les
chiffres sont inquiétants la délinquance
a explosé en 2010 8 par rapport à
l'année 2010 est qui marquait déjà une
très forte hausse des actes délictueux
augmentation de la délinquance et
malaise croissant des forces de l'ordre
alors jusqu'au susi tirent leur source
de la même cause a une incapacité à
prendre en compte les besoins de ceux
qui nous protège le président de la
république pendant sa très longue
intervention la semaine dernière n'a pas
fait allusion à la question de la
sécurité des français
monsieur le premier ministre la
responsabilité de cet échec
un combat votre gouvernement inutile de
me répondre que cette hausse est la
faute des gilets jaunes en 2017 il n'y
avait pas de gilet jaune inutile de me
répondre que cela vient de loin
l'augmentation de la délinquance ne peut
être considéré comme une fatalité
comptez vous monsieur le premier
ministre revoir la feuille de route des
ministères de l'intérieur et de la
justice afin de mettre un terme à la
croissance de l'insécurité dans notre
pays
la parole est à monsieur laurent nunez
de secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'intérieur
non madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
permettez moi de vous répondre d'abord
de me donner des chiffres que vous
annoncez puisque la délinquance en 2018
n'est pas si catastrophique que ça je
crois que vous pour vous rappeler que
les cambriolages ont baissé les
atteintes aux biens ont baissé les vols
dans les véhicules ont baissé
je pense que vous devez confondre avec
le premier trimestre 2010 9 qui
effectivement pour m emes 2019
effectivement nous enregistrons une
hausse des items de la délinquance et
notamment des atteintes aux biens des
cambriolages effectivement mais
uniquement au premier trimestre 2010 9
et pas en 2018 simplement vous dire que
nous avons bien conscience du travail
des policiers et des gendarmes qui est
devenu bien plus compliqué cela ne vous
a pas échappé avec la menace terroriste
nous en parlons en
il ya un instant avec de nouvelles
menaces comme les menaces cyber et la
cybercriminalité avec également deux
nouvelles missions qui leur sont
dévolues comme la gestion de l'ordre
public qui balance ce qui bascule
souvent en violences urbaines en émeutes
et donc nous devons préparer les
policiers à tout cela que faisons nous
pour répondre à cela je crois que vous
le mettez dans le panorama goût fête ses
dix mille emplois en plus sur l'ensemble
du quinquennat
ce sont des moyens budgétaires en plus
ces 300 millions de parents que nous
allons investir dans l'immobilier pour
la police nationale pour la gendarmerie
nationale ce sont des policiers des
gendarmes que nous déchargeons des
tâches indues notamment des tâches
procédurales des tâches administratives
des gardes statiques pour qu'il soit
présent sur le terrain et faire ce
qu'ils aiment faire être présent auprès
de nos concitoyens et lutter
effectivement effectivement contre
dallas délinquance donc nous engageons
énormément de moyens en faveur des
policiers et des gendarmes
nous concevons de nouvelles doctrines
opérationnelle qui empêche comme c'était
trop le cas auparavant
il ya dix ans c'était encore le cas on
travaille en tuyaux d'orgue c'est fini
nous déployons des dispositifs de
coopération opérationnelle
le premier ministre l'a dit pour la
lutte antiterroriste je pourrais
longuement développé tout ce que nous
faisons en matière de lutte contre les
stupéfiants ou les services apprennent à
travailler ensemble pour obtenir de
meilleurs résultats dans la lutte contre
la délinquance
et vous savez sur certains territoires
nous avons multiplié par cinq les
réseaux de stupéfiants démantelé
ceux là mêmes qui viennent gangréné nos
cités causé tant de tracas nos
concitoyens policiers et gendarmes sont
efficaces et la politique du
gouvernement l'est tout autant en
matière de sécurité intérieure
madame raymond pas vers ont disposé de
44 secondes pour une réplique monsieur
le ministre une commission d' enquête du
sénat a fait à la fois un constat et des
propositions gouvernement pour lutter
efficacement contre le malaise des
forces de l'ordre et l'augmentation de
la délinquance
vous le savez par votre expérience vous
n'aurez des résultats que si le
management de la police n'est pas
profondément revue si la réponse pénale
aux actes délictueux n'est pas certaine
et enfin si une loi de programmation sur
la sécurité intérieure ne vient pas
apporté aux policiers et aux gendarmes
les moyens dont ils ont besoin
si tout ne peut pas être rattrapé
rapidement il est nécessaire d'ouvrir
une perspective positive pour redonner
le moral à nos forces de l'anp
drain